[Music]
hello and good afternoon and welcome to
i'd like to know our question and answer
program one of our favorite programs and
we hope one of yours because it gives us
an opportunity to speak to you to hear
your questions and it gives us the
chance to do something that we love to
do and that is study the word of god and
share from the word i am c.a murray an
associate speaker here at secrets on
seoul and i'm in the company of my
colleagues in ministry pastor stephen
bohr our founder and president
and pastor daniel miranda an associate
speaker and really in charge of our our
latino work and doing pastor i think an
excellent job amen amen good student of
the word and a good colleague at the
table he he anchors this part of the
table quite well and we praise the lord
we have a great time doing this program
because as i said it gives us a chance
to answer your questions and we make you
this promise as we always do if an
answer can be found from the word of god
we will find that answer and give it to
you from the word of god
we
are convicted and convinced
that we are a little late in earth's
history to really talk about the things
of men and to spend time answering
questions from our own minds in our own
hearts what you need is a word from the
lord amen and so that is what we
promised to give you a word from the
lord if a word from the lord can be
found we will find it and give it to you
now as you see our our packets here
they're getting rather thick
many many questions are coming and that
says a couple of things that says one
that there are many people who have
questions that there are many people who
are watching this particular program
which is pleasing to us and that there
are many issues that need to be
discussed
from time to time so if you don't hear
your question
the first time that you watch the
program or perhaps even the second time
please know that we're getting to it
we're coming but we want to give each
question do deference spend as much time
as is necessary without lingering but
certainly we want to respect your
questions and the time it took for you
to pose them and to write them we want
to give them due difference and a good
answer so we we don't move uh with speed
always we try to move with accuracy and
with the blessing of the holy spirit so
send your questions in should you like
to get it on the fun send your questions
to tv
at some tv dot o r g that is tv at some
tv.org
and we will get to them as soon as we
possibly can
and we thank you in advance for
participating in the show i'm going to
ask pastor miranda if he would not open
our program with prayer and then pastor
if you would go into the first question
we'll launch right out
yes
gracious heavenly father as we delve
into your word we pray for the holy
spirit that inspired the bible author
that he may guide our minds into
the
word of god so that we might
just
speak your words and not our own words
we pray all these in the name of jesus
amen
well this question comes from
someone whose name is not easy to
pronounce
i think it would be a liu deng
garang
and
this question has to do it's pretty long
it has to do with
uh the celebration of christmas i'm just
going to read
number one in what he sent us
how can you
harmonize i think probably would be the
meaning
verse 7 saying with a loud voice fear
god and give glory to him for the hour
of his judgment has come
and worship him that made heaven and the
earth and the sea and the fountains of
waters how can you harmonize that with
the christmas festival which originated
from pagan practice such as the rebirth
of the sun gods and saturnalia which is
defined as the ancient roman festival of
saturn in december
a period of general mary making and the
predecessor of christmas
the solstice festival the christmas tree
santa claus the christmas father
christmas gift burning candles and
anything related to christmas festival
or ancient pagan festivals
and then this person of course provides
uh some additional paragraphs where the
gist is the same so the big question is
how can you harmonize revelation 14 6-7
with the celebration of christmas
you know every time
people ask this question
i i think the bottom line of this of the
question is whether
we worship pagan deities or or paganism
idols
by using some of the
uh or or or copying some of the
practices of christmas into our churches
like the tree and all those things so i
believe people who ask this question are
very sincere they love the lord and they
just want some clarity on this
because
it is true that
christmas and many of these symbols have
pagan origins
but how do we
how do we address this from a biblical
perspective
if we use a pagan symbol
are we are we being pagans are we
worshiping that idol
i like to go to first corinthians
chapter 8 where
we find
a similar discussion now this is not
speaking about christmas
this is speaking about foods offered to
idols but i'm going to draw a principle
from here
in verse 1 it says now concerning things
offered to idols we know
that we all have knowledge
knowledge pops up but love defies so
notice that paul here is going to
address about things
offered to idols this is foods and then
he says now we all have knowledge what
is the knowledge that he's talking about
that we all have
uh verse 4
gives us the answer therefore concerning
the eating of things offered to idols
we know that an idol is nothing in the
world and that there is no other god but
one so he's establishing the truth he's
saying well we know those are idols
and we know that there is only one god
and then
he goes
to verse 7 and he says however
there is not in everyone that knowledge
for some with consciousness of the idol
until now eat as a thing offered to an
idol and their conscience being weak is
defiled
so what is the point that paul is trying
to make here the problem is not
eating foods offered to idols it was
very difficult to tell what what had
been offered to an idol or not but some
people were
being
troubled by this practice and they were
saying that because
some of the christians were buying from
these markets the food that had been
offered to idols then we were worshiping
the idols
and paul is saying well
we do not buy the food or we don't eat
that food because we're off we are
worshiping the idol we know that an idol
is nothing we only worship god so i
would say the same applies uh to
christmas
ellen white and and our brother here
quotes this
uh she says
um
here
and this is a quote from ellen white
letters of inquiry have come to us
asking shall we have a christmas tree
will it not be like the world we answer
you can make it like the world if you
have a disposition to do so or you can
make it as unlike the world as possible
so the problem is not the tree
the problem is not the food offered to
idols in corinthians
this is how the way you make it
when we go to the bible
the old testament for example we see
that many of the things that the jews
did that god had commanded they had
similarities with pagan practices
but there was a difference in the way
that the jews practiced them they had a
different aim they had a different
purpose the purpose was to worship god
so
that would be my contribution on this
i don't know if pastor ca or pastor bohr
have you i think it would be a good idea
to finish that statement that you read
from the writings of ellen white
because she says
there is no particular sin
in selecting a fragrant evergreen
and placing it in our churches
now here comes the issue
but
the sin lies in the motive
which prompts action
and the use which is made of the gifts
placed upon the tree
so
god judges all acts according to the
motive well said you know
if i have a christmas tree in my house
well i'm not worshiping that christmas
tree
i know i'm not thinking that uh the
ancients you know they used to worship
christmas trees
it's just a custom that exists in the
world today
uh you know of putting an ornamental
tree it's it's like an ornament but
there's no worship rendered to it
there's no sacredness to it
and so uh i think that uh
of course if individuals are have the
motive motivation of uh worshiping the
tree like the ancients that would be a
different story
you know what is sad you know everything
that the the pagans did
the
the the evergreen is called so because
it stays green
and the the the pagan mind was impressed
with that every other tree dropped its
leaves and and at least titularly died
this one held its greenness and and and
stayed green and lovely throughout the
winter and they were impressed by that
and of course that that moved into
worship
um there's another series of texts that
that sort of bear on this i'm in romans
chapter 14 where uh
uh paul is talking about a day
and those who who honor a particular day
and of course there are some who try to
use this as for the sabbath but this is
not the sabbath exactly the sabbath is
written and spoken of differently so you
can't you can't apply this to the
sabbath but we're talking about days
that people venerate and people honor
and and really it gives us a mechanism
for dealing with people who disagree
with us about the importance of a
particular day or a particular practice
uh one of the things that says we need
to we not need not to dispute with those
people don't turn it into a fight don't
turn it into a contest but work with
them
and and and respect them and let
everyone be convinced in their minds
show them the biblical evidence show
them the spirit of prophecy evidence and
then allow them to be convicted in their
own mind because there are some things
gentlemen i think you realize and
understand and know
that are not salvific issues exactly
they're not going to usher us into the
kingdom they're not going to keep us out
of the kingdom
and if we try to make them salvific
issues we put them in the wrong place we
give them the wrong sort of standing
so let everyone be convinced in in in
their mind
in
on the island of hispaniola it's shared
by the dominican republic
and haiti
i've been to both countries several
times in the dominican republic it is
hard to go into a church during the
holiday season and not see a tree
in the church
in the haitian side
it is very rare to go into any church
and see a tree
they're just totally opposite in their
in their acceptance or rejection of
christmas when i was the the chairman of
the board of one of our uh colleges well
atlantic union college
i remember the haitian students walked
out of the men's dorm because someone
put up a wreath so they they are very
strong to the right and their others who
are strong to the left so which one is
weak
you know are those who do not are they
weak are those who do are they weak well
the bible says whichever one you call
weak
countenance them in the lord you know
don't treat them like aliens because
this is not an issue that should be
placed in that way
i happen to think trees are pretty and
they smell nice i just
no problem with that yes so uh it gives
us a mechanism for dealing with people
with whom we disagree exactly and our
brother here asks after after he quotes
ellen why he says what is the motive of
putting a christmas tree in in church
during christmas season and not other
season
if it is not ancient pagan practice in a
decorated way
well ellen y answers that question she
says for charitable purposes
to
grow the work of god why not in a
different season because people don't
think about christmas and any other time
of the year precisely it is only during
that season that people are more
sensitive to the birth of jesus christ
we know that jesus christ wasn't born in
that day but yet we can use the season
the occasion
to
redirect the minds of the people toward
nobler aims
you know
what satan has done
is take
the objects
that symbolized christ
and he's stolen them for himself well
said yes like for example
the son
the sun is a symbol of christ
but what has satan done he's gotten
people to worship the sun
or on the day of the sun
the rock
idols were made out of rocks
the rock represents christ satan has
taken it to represent
false gods
the tree
you know the tree the pagans
change the meaning of the tree
when christians like the evergreen it's
the same yesterday and forever it's a
symbol of christ
so satan has stolen the symbols that
belong to christ if we have the
motivation that it's a symbol
of christ the tree in the church which i
think is what ellen white is saying
because she says we're to bring our
offerings yes and place our offerings on
the tree on the tree the tree is a
symbolic of bringing them to christ
you know when i was in wyoming pastoring
the church there in torrington wyoming
every christmas we had a custom there i
was only there for three christmases
but
we would buy some little hearts in a
craft store
and then we would have the chill we
would give them to the children the
children would come and place the hearts
on the tree which was symbolic of the
fact that they were giving their hearts
to jesus amen
you know that was the motivation the
motivation is not to celebrate
saturnalia and you know the pagan
customs of worshiping the tree you know
it has nothing whatsoever to do with
that it's totally disconnected from the
pagan context yes of the ancients
a couple things come to mind very
quickly i i have a sermon called little
boys grow up there there there is a
certain sensitivity to this time of year
through the christmas time of year
everybody loves the baby jesus nobody
loves nobody has a problem with babies
it's once he grows up and begins walking
and talking and giving commandments
that's when people begin to reject him
but all babies are pretty much the same
uh once they begin to talk then you know
what you're dealing with well that's
when people begin to well okay i don't i
don't want him but long as in a baby in
the crib everybody loves him right one
of the things that that satan has stolen
is the rainbow uh i was just going to
mention that yeah i i figured you were
heading that way
is the rainbow you know it's it it has
this association with the
lgbtq community now but that's not god's
original intent so just because satan
has co-opted something
and and and and and given it a negative
connotation doesn't mean that christians
need to back away from the original
beauty
the celebration of the birth of christ
now any bible student knows and knows
very quickly
that christ was not born december 25th
so we know and understand that but a
holiday that celebrates his birth
given the knowledge that we we don't
know the date and god has done that i
believe specifically and purposefully uh
that turns men's minds to jesus we have
so few opportunities to do that when we
get one i think we should take full
advantage of it you know you have that
famous painting
where jesus is on the cross
and you have the the ten commandments in
the picture you have a rainbow over the
cross
um i guess i guess that would be uh
paganism because you're using a rainbow
rainbow that that you know the lgbt
community uses
uh the point is
that
once again ellen white says what is your
motivation yes for doing it yes and she
also condemns buying bunches of gifts
for all of the family and everything and
forgetting the lord and forgetting the
lord on christmas who who really uh you
know when jesus came he came to save the
human race another thing that i'd like
to mention which
i think is important
is that we need to respect uh
the views that other people have yes you
know when i arrived at fresno central
church
there was a group of probably about 10
to 12 people
who were offended
at that time they would put up two huge
white christmas trees full of lights
on each side of the stage and there were
10 to 12 people that would not come to
church from the time that the trees went
up till the time that the trees were
taken down
and it bothered me because i didn't want
them to miss church but they had their
conviction and i respected their
convictions so
i talked to them i said uh you know
would you come to church if the trees
were not put up
and they said of course we would come if
the trees are not put up so i told the
ladies that put up the trees not to put
up the trees anymore
and the problem was solved they kept
coming to church and nobody was offended
because we didn't put the trees on the
stage it wasn't a matter of principle
for the church
so and then a little bit later on they
said well we need to take the wreaths
down and i said dad you know meet me
halfway the wreaths are not coming down
you know your point and both of you have
made this very strong and very correctly
it's your motivation uh and you see this
throughout the bible two men went into
the temple to pray
one is justified one is not because of
what's going on in the heart why are
they there what are they doing uh
uh what's the motivation behind what
they're doing is it just to show
something to men and women or are you
really worshiping god so motivation is
the key i believe what you're doing and
why you're doing it
don't don't judge in other words
there's probably people that are
listening out there that that are saying
that secrets unsealed is an apostasy
because of what we said
well you know
we want to respect
the convictions
that individuals have regarding
the christmas tree etc
but they need to respect the views of
others we need you know people grow
in their experience and their knowledge
you have to give room to people to grow
in their understanding of things and and
not uh not say well you know this person
is totally apostate because of what they
do
so so we need to be respectful of others
when it does not involve a divine
principle as you were mentioned when
it's not an issue of salvation yes we
need to have some flexibility
in the church amen amen and amen
alrighty i think we have done you know
it's funny we
we took a good part of the on that one
question but i think it's important
because it comes up periodically
periodically and we come to it again and
again pastor what's our next next issue
our next question okay i think probably
uh pastor miranda would be the best
answer this one because uh you know he's
just finished did you finish i still
have four presentations yeah he's doing
a 25 part series on the sanctuary still
has a few to do
and so you know he's done a lot of study
into the symbolism of the sanctuary so
here's the question
hello secrets unsealed
i would like to be helped in
understanding the difference between the
sin offering and the burnt offering
because to me it seems like they are
were all given for an atonement
if they serve the same purpose
when
then why did god give two ordinances to
symbolize one thing
and if they had different roles they
played in describing the work of christ
what are those roles please help me with
this
well that is a very good question
well there is a lot to say about the
offerings the scene offering and the
burnt offering
but there
there are a lot of similarities because
uh the the
you have to confess the scenes over the
offering and that's almost in all the
offerings except the peace offerings or
the meal offering and the drink
offerings but
every offering has a specific emphasis
in the case of sin offerings and
trespass offerings
they have to do with sin uh forgiveness
of sin
in the case of the burnt offering that
also has to do with forgiveness of sin
but that goes beyond
the burnt offering
the word allah in hebrew means the whole
thing
whereas in the scene offering only a
part of the offering was offered the
rest was for them for the priest
but in the burnt offering everything was
burnt
on the altar which
alludes to
a daily and complete consecration to god
as a nation and as individuals because
the nation
uh was supposed to offer a burnt
offering but also individuals burnt
offerings were all also offered for the
cleansing and race statement of the
lepers when they were going to be
introduced back to the camp
in the time of a birth of a child
parents were supposed to offer a burnt
offering as a meaning of consecrating
the child and to god
cleansing the lepers that was another
purpose for which burnt offerings were
offered
the consecration of the priest
the completion of the nazirite vow
and
for personal
consecration
special circumstances it seems like
there's uh certain events in the life of
the person
yes exactly whereas the sin offerings
uh were were given when there were sins
in the case of the sin offering because
there is a difference between sin
offering and trespass offering the sin
offering was
more for
sins of ignorance
uh we find that in leviticus chapter 4
verses
and two
so
that is the basic definition of
of or the basic differentiation of this
offering so scene offering we could
summarize it as
all my sins are christ's
the trespass offering we could say all
my guilt is christ's
the burnt offerings would be all my
my life my entire
being is christ's
uh the
meal offering
all what i have is christ's the drink
offering
all my life because the wine represents
the the blood which is the life of all
my life is christ the peace offerings
christ is my joy christ is my peace
so
in the
the two pigeons and red heifer
christ is my cleanser
he is my physician he's my healer so the
the offerings have these different
emphasis in in the way we we approach to
god
good the
it just added
and well done daniel
that when the people were going to
church synagogue tabernacle they were
going to school
you were dealing with a largely
illiterate
congregation
so they learned by what they did
and so each of these things showed
different aspects of god's dealing with
with man uh
the names that that god was going to
jehovah jair jehovah rapha jehovah nisi
uh each of them dealing with different
aspects of god's provisionary uh
provisions for his people and it was the
same way with the different kinds of
offerings each of them uh for different
trespassers but also each of them showed
a different aspect of god's dealing with
his people
you know we don't have enough time for
another question
so maybe we could just take a few
moments to talk about the anchor school
of theology
that's going to take place in denver
you know this year it's taking place in
denver colorado at a marriott hotel
uh from
march 28 to april 3 starts on monday and
ends on sabbath the following sabbath
and this year
the subject of study is what jesus said
to new testament christians amen amen
amen as many christians say i'm a new
testament christian well we're going to
prove
most of the beliefs of the seventh-day
adventist church from the new testament
okay we'll refer to the old testament
when it's related to something in the
new testament
but you know we have uh about 60 people
signed up seven uh seven already have
signed up for uh the online because
we're gonna live stream it
so i would encourage everyone to
uh you know check it out on our website
check out the anchor school of theology
in denver it's gonna be a great
experience we're going to there's 24
lessons 24 hours of instruction in the
course of the week so i encourage you
all to
go to our website and get information
and if you can go to beautiful denver
with nice clean air add a couple of days
to go up into the mountains
and it'll be a wonderful experience yes
if you listen to the statements of those
who have attended in the past
you will attest to the fact that pastor
bohr is a an uncommonly fine teacher god
has given him that gift and that gift is
on full display uh during this time uh
he will not say it about himself so we
will say it for him about him we'll give
him his flowers while he is yet alive
that you will come away enriched you've
got study notes
you've got a wonderful time together
you will learn you will grow you'll be
refreshed you'll be inspired you'll be
informed and you will be blessed so you
want to make your reservation and make
it soon because uh sooner than you can
expect
anchors will be here amen and we praise
the lord for that
well gentlemen our time has fast slipped
into eternity and
we've had another good sitting together
again send your questions in we will do
the best to get to each and every one of
them we promised that we will see you
again next week same time same place
same station god bless you we'll see you
again soon
[Music]
you